well listen Janet I really wanted to
kind of set the tone for this interview
by honestly doing a wellness check how
are you feeling how are you doing during
this time um for me I think it's like
any you know artist whose work is seen
as activism I think for me I've really
just been going deep into the thoughts
and kind of works of the people who came
before me you know the team before us
who really were fighting this fight for
a very long time and kind of laid the
groundwork for us and so you know the
works of James Baldwin and Audrey Lorde
are just two of the few that I kind of
look to a Malcolm X and Martin Luther
King and Angela Davis who stood here
with us yeah being able to share their
works on my social - you know maybe new
activists or new voices who may not
quite know that these people existed in
that we're not the first to go through
something like this and so for me that
brings a lot of a lot of comfort is
sharing those kind of words of
encouragement and a blueprint for how we
should move forward and it's so needed I
think that's so important too because as
you just pointed out I feel like you
know George Floyd's death and all the
protests have all since have really
awakened to the country and for a lot of
people are stepping into activism for
the first time but of course you know
the the problems that exist in this
country have existed long before George
Floyd's death there's obvious parallels
between the black lives matter movement
right now and honestly Stonewall in the
gay rights movement you know years ago
have you drawn those same comparisons oh
completely I think that there for me at
least there's never been a sense of
celebrating pride without really
thinking about you know our foremothers
and forebears who were there that night
who literally you know Stonewall was one
of the only safe spaces is where LGBTQ
people could come and gather and
community you know back in people I
think a lot of young people forget and
maybe even people of my generation to
forget that you know it was you were an
outlaw if you were trans or queer that
you know people were you you weren't got
in trouble for not having two items of
gender appropriate clothing and that
alone could lend you to be put into jail
it's
on that fateful nine in 1969 when they
uprise together to say we're tired of
this policing we're not gonna take
another raid on our lives we're not
gonna be surveillance anymore when they
thought that that was the igniting of
the change for LGBTQ people and not to
that charge was led by people of color
poor folk who lived on the street
trans women drag queens you know butch
lesbians who are out there and they were
fighting back because they were the ones
were often most policed most
surveillance most put into jails and so
I think I always have that connective
tissue to our really radical roots as an
LGBTQ movement and among those trans
pioneers and those LGBTQ advocates with
Sylvia Rivera and Marsha Pete Johnson
maybe you could speak to a little bit
about their legacy and what they signify
and what they need to the lgbtq+
movement today yeah you know Marsha P
Johnson and Sylvia Rivera were there
that night they were in community they
were gathering together and they
wouldn't take it anymore they knew that
they needed to fight for their lives or
they were gonna live under this kind of
surveillance for the rest of their lives
and I think that that monumental
self-sacrifice the fact that you would
literally put your body in your own
well-being on the line for the
collective good I think has created a
model for activism across all movements
and I think that one of the great things
about them being re centered as a part
of the narrative that they picked up the
brick or the Molotov cocktail that they
were the ones out there in front of the
police that night fighting back to their
lives that that has created you know
this intersectional approach to how we
should do activism that we really put
those who are the most marginalized
people of color trans and gender
non-conforming people women disabled
folks you know undocumented folks at the
center of our movements because if they
are centered and celebrated and vaunted
weave it all of us the people of our
celebrated centered and bonded we're
confronting and exposing the
inequalities in this country that have
existed for a really long time and it's
hard to take in what message you
particularly for the transgender
community who are struggling during this
time I think my biggest thing is just
you know remember who you are you know
know exactly who you are
uplift and recenter the narrative the
fact that you come from
trans and gender non-conforming folk who
were there that fateful night in 1969 at
Stonewall that we helped ignite this
movement and we deserve space in this
movement and that this woman is also
ours and so what I would say to them in
this time period is to refocus your self
in this to think about the narrative of
where you've come from and where we've
come from and to realize that starting
exactly where you are at your kitchen
table with your family your community
your chosen loved ones that you know you
have those conversations there and then
from there you build more and more and
more to be an activist or to be a
co-conspirator and an accomplice almost
yeah yes an accomplice exactly uh you
know we have to be active we have
anything distant and we have to do the
uncomfortable work of checking and
challenging conversations that at times
can seem maybe a little basic and so I
think I would encourage them to mess up
those conversations and to insert
yourself in them and to do it of course
knowing that your own self care and
safety is of another priority is who I
truly am see we got to talk about pose
because when I watched uh Kandi's death
her murder really in season two I mean I
was a mess and I'm sure you've heard
this from a lot of people a lot of
viewers who watch that show well I was
just so important to tell that story and
what was it like for you to play such a
huge part in that you know it was one of
the hardest scripts to have written
really was never knew love like this
before which really sparred Angelica
Ross is candy and really tells her story
of wanting to be truly seen as she saw
herself you know she saw herself as a
star
and as we saw throughout our series her
great antagonist most times was Billy
Porter his character hotel and so I
think that the culmination of her murder
of her family her sister's finding her
no longer there really spoke and really
centered us in terms of our mission you
know Ryan Murphy and I wrote that script
together and it really was to bring a
spotlight on the epidemic of violence
that surrounds the lives of black and
brown trans women globally not just in
the United States and so for us we
wanted to of course you had to lose a
character that was so special and so
dynamic and to say goodbye to Kandy was
so hard but I think giving her the
justice of being able to speak from the
other side to speak her truth to right
the wrongs than against her and to also
forgive to forgive her parents who may
not have always made the right choices
and I know for a lot of LGBTQ people the
scene with kandi and her parents was
cathartic for so many of us Ida struggle
with that had to struggle with who we
knew ourselves to be and the people we
came from and I think that that's one of
the things that made that script in that
episode so special beyond Angelica's you
know tour de force performance mm-hmm
you know the uplifting nature of what
hos is it's about family and so in the
end she got her trophy she got her tins
across the board by you know singing
looks thinking that beautiful that
infant finally being you know laid to
rest that was such an amazing way to end
that episode to to also experience you
know black joy and just I mean I was
playing us on a repeat after that
episode Jana I think you guys really did
a number on me right it's hard to shake
that episode you know so come on has it
has a whole new really does life now
because of you know you it's almost like
you want to scream dance jump for joy
and cry at the same time it's like
exactly right that's how I felt
I'd still feel that way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys were actually in the middle of
filming season 3 right before production
was halted because of Co vid um do you
have any idea when you guys will be back
into production what that timeline looks
like well we're still you know the
writers we never stopped working so you
know we're still refocusing scripts
changing things because of this whole
new world you know which is gonna
require us to spend more time and to be
even more thoughtful about the scenes
that we need about the amount of people
that can be on a set and so our whole
world is changing in this way and so for
us as producers and writers we just want
to tell the best possible story in the
safest way and so for us of course the
priority of the health of our crew and
our Castle is of utmost importance but
you know we will go back and we will be
doing it hopefully you know when New
York is bouncing back we get to go back
to that great city and tell these super
important you know stories
[Applause]
what kind of changes are you guys or how
do you see that the corona virus
pandemic once we're on the other side of
it will impact your production
particular because I read a report that
there might be no kissing scenes or any
ballroom scenes and poses or any truth
to that I don't I think you know we're
definitely gonna have ballroom scenes
there's lovemaking and love and hugs and
all that stuff I think we just have to
figure out the best ways of filming that
you know I know that we're coming up
with contingency plans in terms of our
fall sequences which would be the ones
that are the hardest for us to shoot
because historically from the very first
pilot until you know I got shut down
directing the season three premiere pose
our ball scenes you know there's 300
people in a room yeah there's a lot of
energy and a lot of you have to be close
and you have to have all that stuff so I
think we're figuring about creative ways
with the use of visual effects okay of
different kinds of staging to be able to
keep the cast and also our background
actors safe you know we can't we can't
forget that you know our our background
actors are real life you know trans and
queer LGBTQ people living in the Bronx
and Harlem and in Brooklyn and so they
are more at risk you know and all you
know compromise
so we're thinking about creative ways of
making sure that we can still get those
great glamorous glorious celebratory
shots while also keeping everything
everyone's safe so for us that's the
biggest challenge is thinking through
that I think everything else would like
one to two to three people in a scene
will be easy figure out how we're gonna
do our dinner table scenes now and do
you eight people around that funky
Evangelista table but thankfully for the
premiere where we shot all of that so
much praise Jesus one done haha good I
know it's gonna be a challenge because
it's also you can't have posed without
those ballroom scene so I I know you
guys have your work cut out for you this
is our screenwriter aren't you Coleman
please
you're colored I love it you know and
you definitely tackled those stories
head-on especially and all your work but
in Hollywood I know that you had
co-wrote two episodes that specifically
address you know black issues in the
entertainment industry how would you say
those issues that played out on
Hollywood are similar to today yeah
there was no real big time jump that I
really need to make talk about you know
what it means to be a black screen
writer or a black woman in front of the
camera those are things that I knew on
an intimate level just from my own
experiences and so I think what was so
great about Hollywood is that we were
able to shed light in an entertaining
way about the disparities that are there
in terms of opportunities for folks of
color in Hollywood and how the system
initially wasn't billed for say a
starlet like Camille played by Laura
Harrier or a black out a screenwriter
and like Archie played by Jeremy Pope
you know for me I wanted to make sure
that I used those characters and their
journeys and struggles and triumphs to
be able to allow other people who are
dreaming of being a part of this of this
world to see that it has always been
that way and that this is a new
possibility for futures by having this
kind of fantastical revisionist history
of it all without forgetting the actual
bikes that had to be won in battle in
order to get where we need to go
absolutely this studio is risking
everything for our V scene push back
and suddenly everything goes dark again
was it meant to have the support of
someone like Ryan Murphy in your pursuit
of truth and representation on TV have a
mentor like Ryan it's just been a huge
gift you know he really just dropped
into my life I had just finished doing
the book tour for my second book
surpassing certainty when he requested a
meeting for me with me and I didn't know
what the meeting was about I had no idea
about pose I didn't read the Hollywood
trades I was very muchly novice and so
when he told me about this idea I just
knew that it was important and I knew
that I wanted to be a part of crafting
those women stories and so I went on
that gut you know I left New York City
which was the only city that I've really
known and Phaethon and being myself and
I moved to Los Angeles they started
writing on that show a week later after
that meaning and and he's changed my
life he's been such a great mentor he's
been such a great guy he's been talked
about being an ally a powerful white
ally to death one who has leveraged his
own privileges and his own access into
these spaces to say this is a young
woman you all need to be paying
attention to he's going to change the
world I'm telling you now and he gave me
opportunities and supported me through
those opportunities from you know
Hollywood and posed to politician and
Janet Cooke what she's executive
producing so it's been great to have
someone who champions me and believes in
me but I think for other you know folk
who have privilege I think Ryan is a
great example of being someone of power
who wields that power to bring other
people in that's why I need more stuff
from you guys I need more more and more
I just can't get enough I been such a
huge fan obviously what you guys are
doing is such important work and so it
was important for us that we talk to you
pacifically especially in light of
everything going on so Jana I have to
thank you thank you thank you a thousand
times over for your time appreciate you
how much you're doing that's not
appreciated absolutely
[Music]